this weekend 200 europeans took part in
a historic event bringing together
citizens from 27 member states
people from all walks of life came to
the european parliament in strasbourg to
participate in the first european
citizens panel of the conference on the
future of europe
we wanted to start to hear your desires
your demands your ideas your intentions
your fears also your hopes
about uh the future of europe for three
days they discussed issues including
tackling youth unemployment better
social protection for all workers and
the importance of access to sports and
culture for everyone i think it's uh
an opportunity of a lifetime meeting so
many people from so much countries
everyone brings their own story brings
their own piece to the puzzle and it's
just so amazing colorful both in small
working groups and all together they
debated how to make the eu more
sustainable and socially just citizens
highlighted the challenges and
opportunities of digitalization and ai
especially
another 200 eu citizens will participate
in next weekend's panel on european
values and democracy this will be the
second of four panels covering key
themes related to the future of europe
the outcome of the panels will help
shape the conference conclusions in 2022
[Music]